it was great because I'm coming into
something that has been and so much
foundation so many roots so it was just
joining a family oh that felt weird mill
in theaters this weekend Avengers
endgame find out who if anybody will
return from the snap this is your
weekend ticket don't blow on me I don't
know if I'm stable yet use the stones
again so that's gonna use them to bring
everyone back just like that yeah just
like that even if there's a small chance
that we can undo this I mean we owe it
to everyone who's not in this room to
try dust yourself off for this one your
friendly neighborhood Avengers are back
well most of them some of them
statistically technically probably half
of them Avengers endgame is the 22nd
movie in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
and again features many of your favorite
superheroes together in the same movie
as the direct sequel to Avengers
infinity war this movie picks up after
Thanos is snap destroyed half of all
living things in the universe and in one
supposedly final battle the remaining
team members join forces to make
everything cool again
[Music]
this movies for you if you love the
Marvel Cinematic Universe you're a
living breathing human being or you want
to see where the phrase oh snap comes
from they really should make the tickets
half off or like me you like your coffee
you would happen have I'm gonna go with
my half-brother dusty this movies
nothing to sneeze at because you got
dust in your face that one doesn't work
fit variety kale fired from weekend
ticket you like that that's in variety
that is your weekend ticket it's an easy
choice see Avengers endgame and check
back next week for some rom-com Seth
Rogen and if you want to find out who
comes back maybe you should talk to the
writers because they knows do this like
Scott and kale fired from weekend
together
[Music]